so we're always looking for ways to  improve ourselves I'm more than others  Greg but a great way after the holidays  to be able to jumpstart your metabolism  is a new book by my friend Dave's and  zanko he has 20 New York Times  bestsellers and it's fantastic it's  called the super metabolism diet the  two-week plan to ignite your fat burning  furnace all right so that's what you can  do Ernest I love this one in particular  it teaches you how you can lose weight  while you're even sleeping well I'm  doing a Westworld robot power down what  you're seeing that's how you lose weight  Frank's always think they had him by the  book first certain foods can really help  your metabolism to the point of someone  who is half of your age so check it out  you will not be disappointing it's got  the ABS diet book they eat this not that  you can see them on GMA okay